in a jacket crown the hmm I have found
the final risk we're headed for
vengeance but if all King bourget your
fellow sword folks are already
assembling outside the tool I'll meet
you there as soon as I'm finished up
here and a y'all so they demand let's
stay there fetch and damn the move we
should risk Latino turnover yeah yeah
yeah let's go get for the possible on
our left you know what I'm saying
all right here where's the good
hail hillfield hey what's the Legion
doing here damn Imperial spies well
should be fun for us at least they don't
seem to know we're here yet ready to
spill some Imperial blood for Skylar you
better baby that's what up well you must
be the new model here in four welcome to
the spice gutter listen up those
Imperials aren't here by coincidence
they're spies must have found out we
know about the crown and they don't want
us to have it but they both stand in our
way I know some of you are expedient and
they know men on the other side but
remember this thing are they energy and
Tara wearing a [ __ ] killed people wits
about you and what your shield brothers
back Oh Frick storm coke is counting on
us to bring him back that crown and
that's exactly what we're going to do
follow me quickly and quietly now and
what they're just on the ground before
they even know we're here bet that
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you want to
that is that
then I can hear that's the way I like
short and bloody they never knew what
hit them he better not make the mistake
of underestimated the Legion plenty of
them are north same as us we have the
advantage of surprise big time things
will have is over here you're on out
enough pork let's go kill some Imperials
it's like a [ __ ] mess a is what its
gonna be
yeah I can fish brother n gone
there we gotta go
hey Mac
nothing but horsehair I don't like
yo afraid all these [ __ ] is the first
without you yeah you like mr. and a
samurai match that booty there's a lot
on my short Ali came with to think
straight
look [ __ ] sick sucker and then what
thick is getting hotter by the day if I
think in this color is what does he's
talking crazy
they have any car too bad we can't read
these carvings who knows what's the
secret act again that one thing at a
time he is for the crowd any of these
causing so a crowd looks like this is as
far as the Imperials God he had one of
these pictures tells us where the crown
is I'm betting wow it's repairing the
wave and can dragonfly what is that
chicken hey you [ __ ] them in
oh okay you know wolf dragonfly dragon
with that door that looks like some kind
of flora statue
their way again let's get that good job
oh yeah that was that was argued I've
got a bad feeling
okay come on boy let's spread out and
keep the gun on blooded do what you do
best keep something in
and look at so far now face shut how's
it going on Lotus find anything yet that
if akshat
now chef sorry
how's it going on blood finds anything
yet that's not it yes get guys keep
guard
the [ __ ] is this
Oh
that's okay
with the crown its weakest you can tell
rubric evil will stick around thank you
granny
Wow like that a bit quicker way out of
here right
ok
okay wow it's like the beginning and at
me I'll take that may chase s
she said what the [ __ ] are you yeah
that's good question [ __ ] attacked if
I'd love a good quest I love a good
class got to thinking I do the cooking
and cleaning around the palace damn
telius he spoke with Pam him that old
there was right did you run it sergeant
spirit I get all the details I'm glad
you're here I have a message yeah I can
tip it to the y'all of white deliver
this axle bolts the greater men who
understand each other there are but ball
group will know my meaning keep your
wits about you y'all of white I'm not
much of a stratagem the good old pic to
my counsel back yeah